Texas Republicans seem to have a thing about
volunteering other people to do things that
maybe they don't want to do. Remember back
in the earlier phases of the virus in Texas,
when Texas Republican Lieutenant Governor
Dan Patrick went on TV and said, listen,
grandma would sacrifice herself to save the
economy by which he really meant the stock market.
And then we said, well, grandma
isn't Dan Patrick's to sacrifice
now, former Texas Republican governor and
former Trump secretary of energy Rick Perry
is saying Texans are willing to continue going
without power so that the federal government
doesn't get involved in their energy market.
It's not his role to decide who wants to go
without power. In a blog that was posted
on House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy,
his website, Rick Perry wrote, quote, Texans would
be without electricity for longer than three days
to keep the federal government out of
their business. How does he know that?
Try not to let whatever the crisis
of the day is, take your eye off
of having a resilient grid that keeps America
safe personally, economically and strategically.
Personal responsibility, right?
Rick Perry can say what he wants,
what he's willing to do, but who is he to say how
many days other Texans are willing to go without
power or heat or water for political reasons? What
he is saying here is some of you may die to keep
our power unregulated by the federal government,
but that's a sacrifice I am volunteering you
to make, what for people who maybe aren't
up to speed on this issue. Understandably,
Texas has a power power grid that's run by
I believe the acronym is Bercot Earshot.
And it's the only power grid in the United States
that doesn't cross state lines. And as a result of
that, it's not under the oversight of the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission. Rick Perry likes
that. A lot of Texas Republican elected officials
like that. And what Rick Perry is saying here is
because he wants to keep that going, it's the
equivalent of saying, listen, Americans are
willing to have an extra 50000 extra 50000 people
die of covid so that we don't get controlled by
the WHL or something like that. That's essentially
the equivalent of what Rick Perry is saying. Now,
first of all, I doubt it from everybody I'm
talking to in Texas. Nobody, even libertarians and
other people, nobody seems OK with what's going
on so that they can maintain their independence
from any other grids and federal oversight.
Secondly, it's not Rick Perry's call to make.
If there is a power outage, others are willing
to die for Rick Perry's separatist views. Now
that that's that that just can't be.
And one other thing on this I've said,
despite the hypocrisy of Texas Republicans like
Ted Cruz demanding federal relief money for Texas
now, but was against federal relief money when
it was needed in New York and New Jersey for
Hurricane Sandy, despite him being a disgusting
hypocrite. I don't want Texans to go without
federal aid. I still want the people of
Texas to get the relief money because
they need it. I don't want to hold it back
from them because Ted Cruz is a hypocrite.
But there is a real question here about if
Texas refuses to become part of a bigger,
broader, interstate resilient power grid, should
they continue to be bailed out by the feds?
There are options for preventing this by being
part of a multi state power grid, and they refuse,
but then they still want the money when it fails.
Again, I don't want to deny the people of Texas
anything, but shouldn't someone make it clear
to Texas, you've got to join us. If you want us
to bail you out, you have to join the power grid
because otherwise you're bringing this problem on
yourselves. They had power outages in 2011 for
similar reasons. They got a report telling them
how to prevent this from happening again. They
didn't do anything that the report said. And now
they immediately and defiantly say, give us the
cash. There has to be some limit at some point.
And somebody needs to sit Ted Cruz down and
talk about it. Except Ted Cruz flew to Cancun
in the middle of all of this.
I want to talk about that next